c'est mon grand père était médecin qui
aimait beaucoup et il était médecin dans
votre villa mangwa y est ils avaient une
clinique a été commencée que c'était un
un grand carré blanc parce qu'il était
très doué comme médecin est assez peu
doué comme architecte mais voulait faire
les deux voulaient tout faire de toute
façon crémieux apprendre le russe
s'était c'était vraiment quelqu'un de
bien il est beaucoup plus lourde sur toi
ceci pose en tout cas une touche encore
beaucoup au plan politique aussi parce
qu'ils étaient marxiste non oui il était
communiste mais c'est très sain d'être
communistes dans un pays fasciste et à
12 ans tu t'es retrouvé finalement être
extrémiste de gauche
ça a duré combien de temps car c'est à
dire toujours oui tu croyais en quoi
exactement
j'avais la révolte pas là et aujourd'hui
que le communisme s'est effondré sous
quelle forme cette révolte peut
s'exprimer ainsi
ça a été des choses qui étaient
certainement magnifique dans l'idée ça a
été extrêmement mal appliquée parce que
parce que c'est comme les 68 c'est bien
bon moment passé puis après après
comment comment maintenir une flamme qui
est juste en la structure ans
comment ne pas tuer cette flamme en la
structure ans c'est vraiment très très
difficile et c'est vrai qu'on a appris
que d'être trop trop rigide ça et
risquaient d'étouffer la flamme et qu'il
fallait toujours resté dans la tente du
monde et vivre vivre quand même vivre
c'est quand même bouger chaque jour un
petit pauvre au fur et à mesure des
connaissances et passe ce s'amarrer une
fois pour toutes à un discours
extrêmement établit toujours cherché
cherché plus loin c'est certainement ce
qu'on doit en tirer mais que les
révoltes initiales sont toujours de mise
eh ben je pense que rien du tout je ne
sors luc holtz mais j'en sais rien mon
vieux je ne fais pas de la politique moi
moi je suis une artiste moi je dit que
ils font exploser les choses c'est vrai
que chez toi on écoutait beaucoup brel
et brassens et que l'europe était
considéré comme fasciste lampard à son
capitaine
kapitalis appareils
ben oui mon père me disait que j'étais
une individuelle individualiste
romantique occidental tu as déclaré que
tu étais une déçus du socialisme depuis
la sphère greenpeace enfin oui
certainement ça a été quand même quelque
chose de deux dash est terrible pour moi
parce que je me disais bon voilà au
moins ils vont pas mentir
j'en fais une énormité mais vous pouvez
le dire quoi voilà on est victime ou
même de tout ça et ben non alors ça m'a
quand même s'il a déçu comme plus
longtemps j'ai pensé à l'époque où il ya
eu il ya eu l'appel pour que on voit
tout le temps je me disais que j'allais
faire ça parce que parce que c'était
grave que chirac passe quand il y avait
le pen derrière parce que même si chirac
n'est certainement pas tout à fait la
même chose que le pen fut dire il ya
quand même des passes pas dans son
entourage qui n'en sont pas très éloigné
puis à valéry giscard d'estaing à ça on
sait tous que c'est donc tout ça a été
pour moi dangereux et bon ben voila mais
je ne suis pas contente
non je trouve que c'est que c'est
terrible de se positionner comme il le
fait